today the Matt Walsh show I testified at
a Committee hearing to support a bill
Banning child mutilation the
pro-mutilation Democrats on the hearing
took the opportunity to Ambush me but it
didn't work out quite the way they
planned we'll play the clips and I'll
tell you all about my experience today
also AOC defames lives at Tick Tock at a
Committee hearing in D.C will do the
fact check that the fact Checkers won't
do on that defamation and Airbnb bans
the parents of a conservative
commentator then backtracks plus a
school is forced to apologize after
after serving chicken and waffles for
Black History Month we'll try to figure
out how a delicious meal could possibly
be offensive all of that and more today
on the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
you know as you get older and you have
kids and a lot of things happen in your
life it becomes you get really busy it
can be really hard to uh to maintain a
healthy lifestyle when you've got such a
busy schedule and that's why I'm a huge
fan of balance of nature balance of
nature fruits and veggies are the best
way to make sure that you're getting
essential nutritional ingredients every
single day their products are 100 Whole
Food balance of nature uses a cold
vacuum process that preserves the
natural phytonutrients in whole fruits
and vegetables and encapsulates them for
easy consumption balance of nature sent
a bunch of their products down to the
office for our team to try and everyone
loves them you can go to
bouncenature.com use promo code Walsh
for 25 off your first order as a
preferred customer plus a free fiber and
spice that's balanceofnature.com promo
code Walsh for 25 off your first
preferred order
yesterday I had the opportunity to
testify at a house Committee hearing to
voice my support for legislation Banning
the castration mutilation of children in
Tennessee now I've addressed School
boards in the past as you know but this
was my first time in front of any kind
of legislative committee so it's an
interesting learning experience kind of
like my own Schoolhouse Rock sort of uh
experience and one of the key difference
differences here is that in my school
board speeches I've spoken out against
policies and measures that the boards
were wanting to put into place or or had
already put into place in this case
however I was speaking in favor of a
bill that the majority of the
legislature has already expressed
support for so I didn't need to convince
them of what they already believe or
urge them to do what they're already
going to do but rather my plan was
simply to add my voice of support as a
citizen of the state now
you may be understandably concerned
based on that description that my
appearance in front of this committee
must have been rather boring and lacking
the kind of fireworks that you might
expect and hope for well allow me to
allay those fears because fortunately
for you there were a few Democrats in
the room who though on the losing side
of this issue were still determined to
use my appearance as an opportunity to
try and score some points with their own
base so after I delivered my brief
remarks and all the other witnesses
there were three others on the
anti-mutilation side and four on the
pro-mutilation side they had they had
their turns also to uh to speak and then
the lawmakers on the committee had the
chance to ask us questions the first
question came from a republican who had
a very fair and relevant query about the
off-prepeated claim which we also heard
from other Witnesses uh during the
testimonies that medically affirming
quote unquote Transit identified youth
is necessary to decrease their suicide
rate and because this is the thing that
got everything kicked off I want to play
this clip for it's a little bit long but
it's also it's uh it's an important
Point too so here's my answer to his
question
just a quick question for you we've
heard in the news last week
and even today that
it's pro-life to vote against this bill
we've heard that um
suicides are prevalent
and suicide has impacted my family so
I'm sensitive when I hear something like
that
I I've read some of the stuff that
you've done and I was wondering can you
speak to the statistics
of of
Mental Health
and Suicidal Tendencies
for the people who have gone through
transition for people who have not in
your studies from what I've read can you
can you speak to that I'm sure you
recognized sure uh well the claim that
uh you know doing the chemical
castration drugs or surgery or hormonal
intervention the claim that this
prevents suicide or uh has a positive
psychological effects down the line is
utterly totally baseless there are no
credible long-term studies that bear
that out and one of the reasons for that
is that there couldn't possibly be any
credible long-term studies because we've
never done this to kids on this scale
ever before in history so this current
uh shall we say crop of children they
are the guinea pigs this is this is all
experimental we're sort of trying it out
on them to see if it works now they have
attempted a few times to do studies and
the interesting thing is that the world
Professional Association of transgender
Health wpath which is a radical far left
pro-trans organization they commissioned
a study to try to prove that that
hormones and puberty blockers decrease
suicide rates among trans
uh trans-identified Youth and even in
their own study they found that they
couldn't they couldn't they couldn't
prove it they couldn't make that link
because it's just not possible to do the
other thing I've mention too is that you
know the the
number of trans identified youth has
skyrocketed in recent years we're
talking about exponential 10x 20x growth
just huge numbers having of uh have
increased and what we hear from the
pro-trans side is that well this is not
a social contagion it's just that you
know there's always been this many trans
people it's just that they were not in
an affirming
uh environment before in history and so
they couldn't come out and now for the
first time trans people have have the
ability to live their truth so to speak
well if that's the case and there have
always been these sort of like millions
of trans people and if it's also true
that if we don't affirm them that it
would cause them to commit suicide then
we should be able to look back in
history and find just this unbroken
incredible epidemic of children
mysteriously killing themselves because
they weren't being affirmed as trans and
what you find is that that didn't exist
I mean the the youth suicide rate has
increased exponentially alongside trans
affirmation so trans affirmation causes
the suicide rate not the other way
around the last thing I'll note is that
um the suicide rate among trans identify
people is is Sky High it remains Sky
High all the data shows us it remains
Sky High even after surgery and in fact
in the most reliable day that we have
it's a years after surgery when
suicidality is the highest for Transit
identify people that's the reality
now
so you see all that I make a number of
claims and arguments in that answer
just as I did in my initial remarks that
the Democrats on the panel had the
opportunity to refute if indeed I was
wrong about anything I said and can be
refuted then they had a chance to do it
but but but they couldn't refute it they
had nothing to say which as we've
learned about Democrats will certainly
not stop them from talking so the next
question or what pretended to be a
question came from a greasy little hack
named Caleb hemmer who rather than
discussed the issue at hand instead
decided to try and smear me with that
Media Matters hit piece from my time as
a shock jock morning host 15 years ago
what does that have to do with anything
what what did he think he would
accomplish with this well we'll find out
thank you Mr Walsh I found it
interesting one of our uh people
testified today that they uh had their
gender farming surgery at 16. I know uh
you and former comments mentioned uh
this uh on your blog at about 16 you're
an adult who's mature and can make
decisions uh you're that at 16. I don't
care what anybody says even going so far
as to say you know 16 people uh when
you're 16 you should be married and uh
and could be pregnant or should be
pregnant so I'm curious if 16 is uh a uh
an adult in your view why is this bill
have the minor defined as 18.
yeah that's that's a hit piece you took
from Media Matters uh from something
when I was a radio host uh 13 14 years
ago in my early 20s uh it's also not an
accurate reflection of what I actually
said
um I was talking about
uh the fact that people tended to marry
young historically and that's all that
that was about
um
how does that relate to this
subject
just curious your definition of if you
feel like people are adults with 16
should people are adults at 18. but
actually they're your your brain is not
fully developed until you're 25.
so we should be having a conversation
about whether we should even be doing
these surgeries to people at 18. but
certainly before 18 it's it's absurd I
mean do you do you think that a 16 year
old can meaningfully consent to having
their body parts removed
do you
no
we do not yeah we ask the questions it's
not it's
okay uh representative Hammer you are
recognized
so
that was one gloriously awkward silence
uh even more so for those of us in the
room actually you can't see it from that
camera angle on the clip exactly but
Caleb sat back away from the microphone
when I asked him that question and he
kind of looked off to the side almost
like he was trying to pretend he didn't
hear the question was it was a it was a
bizarre scene
but not so bizarre when you consider
that I had asked a question that Caleb
hemmer simply could not answer he
obviously couldn't say no that 16 year
olds can't consent to having body parts
improved because then he'd be agreeing
with me and with the legislation he
doesn't want to do that but he also
didn't want to come out and say yes that
16 year olds can consent because that
sounds horrific and insane when said out
loud and it puts him in the position of
having to explicitly defend a totally
indefensible proposition you'll notice
it left us they often find themselves in
this kind of situation they they hold
many views that they cannot say out loud
their actual positions on the issues are
often so deranged so inconceivably gross
so morally vacuous and incoherent that
you can defeat them in an argument
simply by asking them to clearly State
their own premise
of course what this means is that
leftists like uh you know leftists
themselves left us like Caleb hemmer
they themselves realize how evil their
own policies are they are deliberately
pushing things that they recognize as
unspeakably wicked which is why they
will not speak it out loud
and this puts people like Caleb Hammer
somewhere somewhere below mere partisan
hacks you've got partisan hacks and then
it's below them that you have the Caleb
hammers of the world
because these are people who are
consciously evil
which also explains why they would
resort to smear tactics against a
private citizen at a legislative hearing
keep in mind by the way that I was not
there as an author of the bill nor was I
testifying as some sort of accredited
expert I didn't stand up there and say
I'm a medical expert and a doctor and
this is what I in fact I introduced
myself as uh I'm a citizen Tennessee I'm
a husband and a father and this is how I
feel about this
um a citizen of Tennessee who supports
the bill
and this is supposed to be a democracy
they tell me right
so the point is that even if they could
succeed in tearing me down and
embarrassing me which sadly for them
they didn't how would that remotely come
close to proving that the legislation is
bad
now if you're wondering how Caleb hemmer
will recover from this humiliation well
he'll do it or he'll try to do it the
most weasily and dishonest way possible
of course so shortly after the hearing
Ben Shapiro posted that full exchange
that you just watched and he posted he
posted it to Twitter
uh hammer responded to the post with a
link to a different video which he urged
people to watch instead to see what
quote really went down now that video
was an edited montage by an obscure
left-wing propaganda rag called the
Tennessee holler and what they did is
they took all the questions that the uh
and not really questions but statements
that the Democrats on the Committee
hearing made to me and they spliced all
that together and then cut out most of
my responses
and then anything else that may have
been especially embarrassing for the
Democrats and pasted all the rest of it
together with a bunch of very obvious
jump cuts and posted that so hammer
therefore is actually claiming that an
edited Montage without my responses is a
more accurate reflection of what
actually transpired than the full
unedited clip
that's how Shameless this guy is
by the way if you're concerned about his
lack of honesty
um and this lack of honesty from an
elected official or perhaps you're not
satisfied with his refusal to answer my
simple question
you could always reach out to him on any
of his social media channels and look
I'm not telling you I want to be very
clear about this I am not telling you
that I want you all to spam his Twitter
and his Facebook and Instagram that I
want hundreds of the you know comments
and everything attacking him I I'm not
I I could not tell you to do that I
couldn't tell you to do that
I just want to make sure that you have
his information so that you can reach
out to him took express your concerns
again he's a he's elected official so
you can find him on Twitter at Caleb
hemmer that's
c-a-l-e-b-h-e-m-m-e-r or Instagram the
same way that you go to Facebook you
have facebook.com Caleb hemmer TN and
then calebhemmer.com contact will take
you to his website and that's the
contact information for his office so
again if you have any concerns about the
behavior of this public official
um or if you really want to know like
does he think that 16 year olds can
consent to having body parts removed he
still hasn't answered that question but
I I bet he'd love an opportunity to
answer it and I and I think he's he he
would he would want to hear from you be
very glad to hear from you so you can
always do that if you want
now there's more though the next
question came from uh Democrat John Ray
Clemens who also had no interest in
talking about the substance of the issue
instead with the slander already covered
by Caleb hemmer Clemens went to the
Democrats second favorite tool in the
box which is credentialism let's watch
can you give us a summary of your
educational background or your health
care education experience Mr Walsh you
recognized my experience in healthcare
your educational background I'm just
curious you you testified as to a lot of
your own research so I'm curious for
what purpose you do that and what
background you have to qualify you to
speak to that well my background that
qualifies me to speak to this is that
I'm a human being with a brain and
common sense and I have a soul and so
therefore I think it's a really bad idea
it's a chemically castrate children that
is my experience
um also I I did now it's true I didn't I
didn't go to college but I did go to
school long enough to learn how to read
so I could read the data for myself and
that's exactly what I've done
representative Clements here and for
what purpose do you um conduct your
research and use this brain of yours Mr
Walsh you're recognized
I use it for the purpose of trying to
protect children from being castrated
and mutilated that's one of the things I
try to do
yeah
thank you Mr chairman you don't use it
to get clicks on your
State application well using it right
now to try to get clicks with this
interaction
of
drawing attention to the fact that this
is happening to children I know you seem
to find it very amusing I don't
yes what qualifies me to speak up
against chopping body parts off of kids
which credentials give me the right to
form an opinion about the sterilization
of middle schoolers I wonder what John
Ray Clements might have said if I told
him that's um I'm also against drowning
bags of puppies in the river I'm not
even a big dog guy but like I don't
think that you should put puppies in a
bag and drown them in the river if I
were to tell them that would even
demanded to know what veterinarian
school I attended
this apparently comes as a shock to Mr
Clements but using your brain and your
conscience it's not the kind of job that
requires a resume or professional
references that's something you're
supposed to be doing all the time
especially when it comes to this
particular issue
but this is all they have they cannot
challenge me on the merits they cannot
debate me on the substance of the issue
they cannot explain why I'm wrong so
instead they will make the case that
whether I'm wrong or right I shouldn't
be saying anything at all
that is real that's the entire argument
that is the only argument I have heard
from these people uh since since I
started talking about this this issue
years ago the only argument they have it
really only boils down to you shouldn't
be talking about this
yet they can't even make that case
convincingly so instead they're left
with the bumbling ridiculous mess you
just witnessed
now there were more questions or
questions I should say after the
exchange we you just saw there another
Democrat representative started reading
my tweets where I advocate for capital
punishment for drug traffickers now what
in the world could that possibly have to
do with the bill in question
well he couldn't explain that and I
didn't have a chance to point out how
irrelevant it was because they wouldn't
let me respond either
so after that happened they basically
got tired of me answering and so for
most of the rest of the time it was just
them talking to me and then if I try to
speak they bang the gavel no this is not
this is not it's not time for responding
democracy in action folks isn't it
inspiring
but this is all predictable of course um
I don't want you to think that I was
surprised or caught off guard that was
their intention but unfortunately they
were using the same tactics on me that a
million hacks and charlatans before them
have already used
what I'll say to the Democrats on the
committee is this if you want to Rattle
me with smears and irrelevant out of
context quotes and bad faith questions
and accusations Etc you're gonna have to
try a lot harder than that a lot harder
or instead
instead of trying to get better at being
gutless smear merchants and disgraceful
hacks you could instead work on becoming
better people
better men
you could stop trying to defend the
indefensible
what you you what you yourself know to
be indefensible you could stop trading
in your soul for the sake of promoting
and defending the most depraved
ideological agenda mankind has ever
known
and instead you could try to be men of
dignity and integrity and moral courage
that's the other option
it's an option that would work out a lot
better for you in a lot of ways
including come Judgment Day I would add
and in the meantime
another bonus maybe you won't make such
asses of yourself in any more committee
hearings
just a thought
now let's get to our headlines
you know companies aren't just selling
products anymore they're selling you
tech companies enrich themselves by
taking your personal data they grab your
web history your email metadata video
searches to create a detailed profile on
you and they sell it off to the highest
bidder when you go online without a VPN
internet service providers they can see
every single website you visit they can
monetize all that stuff they can legally
sell this information without your
consent to add companies and Tech Giants
who then use it to Target you
to keep my data private that's why I use
expressvpn expressvpn reroutes my
connection through an encrypted
encrypted service server that makes it
more difficult for third parties to find
me it sounds complicated but really all
you got to do is on your end is just
open the app Tap a button and that's it
you're good to go if like me you believe
that your data is your business secure
yourself with the number one rated VPN
on the market visit expressvpn.com Walsh
you get three months free that's exp
resvpn.com Welsh expressvpn.com Walsh to
learn more
there was another Committee hearing
yesterday uh so it's a big day for
committees this one was a DC where three
former Twitter Executives have been
called in to answer questions about
Twitter's decision to censor the hunter
Biden laptop story of course rigging
there by the 2020 election by
suppressing relevant information that
might have swayed the voters and that
was all that was the point of it of
course we'll start with this clip where
AOC takes the opportunity to instead of
discussing the issue at hand so there's
um there's a common theme a theme is
emerging instead of talking about that
she instead decides to defame Libs of
tick tock let's watch
uh additionally Miss navaroli are you
familiar with the account Libs of tick
tock
I have heard of it from the news yes
um Mr Roth are you familiar with this
account
yes ma'am I am
are you aware from that from August 11
to August 16th that account posted false
information about Boston Children's
Hospital claiming that they were
providing hysterectomies
to children
yes I am aware of that and other claims
from the account and are you aware that
this lie was then circulated by other
prominent far-right influencers
yes
and are you aware that all these claims
uh which I have reiterated were false
culminated in a real-life harassment and
ultimately a bomb threat to the Boston
Children's Hospital
yes I am aware and this account is still
on that platform today isn't it
regrettably yes it is despite inspiring
a bomb threat due to the right-wing
incitement of violence against trans
Americans in this country because they
cannot
let go of this obsession
with fixating violence and inciting
violence against trans and LGBT people
in addition to immigrants in addition to
women of color this is a party that
cannot pick on anyone their own size
oh the old uh the old punching down
routine right we're punching down when
uh you know there's the LGBT
this is his institutional power like EV
every single major corporation is uh
tripping over itself or on pride month
covering itself in rainbows and so you
know LGBT the most privileged celebrated
group in America
and uh in American history in fact
and yet if you say anything critical of
any not even critical of them if you say
if you remotely say anything critical of
some of the things that some of them do
you're punching down you're punching
down on these poor people
maybe eventually you know we keep
hearing about us and citing violence
people on the right inciting violence
hear about this so much maybe one of
these days one of these people will get
around to providing even like one
example of us inciting violence we'll
keep I keep hearing about it I hear
about how I do it all the time I hear
about who lives of tick tock does it
I'd be really interested to know what
when was that exactly
where's the part where any of us have
said have called on others to commit
acts of violence
so go out into the street and find trans
people and beat them up but when when
have any of us said anything
even like vaguely similar to that
I do have to admit though I was I I was
pretty jealous when I saw this like I'm
um
look not to make it about myself but I
I'm the transphobe of the year
and I don't get a mention here so AOC at
the Committee hearing she wants to go
after her transphobic accounts
lives a tick tock fine I get it but I
don't she defames lives with Tick Tock
and I don't even get an honorable
mention as the transphobe of the year
I'm the award-winning transphobe
me and lives at Tick Tock uh Shia are in
kind of a feud a battle to see who could
be defamed by the media the most and
it's a friendly contest
um I I thought that I'd surge pretty far
ahead with my transphobe of the Year
award I thought that not that I got
comfortable or complacent I just thought
that I got I got a comfortable I do have
a comfortable lead here I can Coast a
little bit uh maybe Pace myself a little
bit more
but then she gets the name drop in a
congressional Committee hearing and uh
suddenly I'm in danger of getting left
in the dust so this shows you how heated
the competition is because this was
earlier yesterday this happened to uh
Chaya and then and then later that same
day I get ambushed and defamed at a
Committee hearing in Tennessee now yeah
hers was Federal I get that
but for me I was there in person so it's
kind of I don't know I think it's kind
of close
it's it's a it's a it's a real
competition though we'll see what
happens
um and ultimately it's who's going to be
this is really what the competition is
um who's going to be transphobe of the
year of 2023 that's the contest and uh I
understand that that's I that I'm going
to need to need to vigorously defend my
title and I plan to
but I see things like this and it makes
me makes me a little nervous
now more to the point of course
what AOC accused Libs of tick tock of
was uh totally false both on on inciting
violence that's obviously completely
made up
but then but then but then also the part
about uh you know misinformation about
Boston Children's Hospital now just to
remind us all so we can all remember
live to Tech talk this was not uh she
didn't post something and say Hey you
know I heard I heard that they do uh
gender affirming hysterectomies I heard
about this
no she did she found a video
a Boston Children's Hospital video
where they talk about providing this
procedure so she was quoting them now
let's go back and watch that video again
just so we can all refresh our memories
gender brooming hysterectomy is very
similar to most hysterectomies that
occur a hysterectomy itself is the
removal of the uterus the cervix which
is the opening of the uterus and the
Fallopian tubes which are attached to
the sides of the uterus some gender
affirming hysterectomies will also
include the removal of the ovaries but
that's technically a separate procedure
called bilateral oophorectomy and not
every gender forming hysterectomy
includes that and people who are getting
gender formic hysterectomies do not have
to have their ovaries removed
okay can we go back to the just the very
beginning of this video again
just start from the top
inner firming hysterectomy is very
similar
summer there
so I just I don't know if this gets in
the camera can you see right there is
that can we see that right on the corner
there it says Boston
now it's again we already established in
the last in in the opening that I don't
have I don't have any medical
credentials I didn't go to college but
so correct me if I'm wrong this reading
thing can be a challenge sometimes for
us uh those of us who didn't go to
college but I'm pretty sure it says
Boston Children's Hospital
and there's a doctor who works there
talking about gender affirming
hysterectomies okay so that's where we
got the idea from where do we get the
idea that Boston Children's Hospital
does gender for me test records well we
got it from them in this video where
they talk about it that's where we got
it
just so you know
but
so what so when when AOC and all the
rest of them when they say that um
this is misinformation what again as
always
misinformation means when they say it it
means inconvenient information it means
information that I wish you didn't know
that is misinformation
all right moving on a little bit on that
same Committee hearing well not moving
past the Committee hearing because
Marjorie Taylor green uh had a few
things to say as well coming from the
opposite perspective and let's watch
that
so glad that your scents are down I'm so
glad you've lost your jobs thank God
Elon Elon Musk bought Twitter and you
know what let's talk about something a
little bit further
it's amazing to me Mr Roth as the head
and Trust of safety at Twitter
your ability or should I say inability
to remove child porn
now here's something that disgusts me
about you and your doctoral dissertation
entitled gay data you argued that minors
should have access to grinder an adult
male gay hookup app minors really
you know Elon Musk took over Twitter and
he banned 44 000 accounts that were
promoting child porn you permanently
banned my Twitter account but you
allowed child child porn all over
Twitter
had become a platform you said
connecting queer young adults you also
wrote on Twitter in 2010 can high school
students ever meaningfully consent
all everything she's saying there's is
correct of course and but the one the
one thing I'll take issue with from
Marjorie Taylor green is she says that
it's uh I think she said it's astounding
to her surprising astounding
um that there was all this child porn
and they didn't take the child porn off
the platform but they were going after
her and they were going after Hunter
Biden's laptop story and taking
conservative content down she's
astounded by that I'm not astounded by
it in the least bit um I'm not I'm not
even remotely surprised by it uh because
they don't look why weren't they
aggressive in removing child porn before
Elon Musk took over because they don't
see child porn as a problem they don't
see child sex abuse as an issue
they just don't
and I know sometimes that can be hard to
wrap your head around because if you are
if you are a decent person and you do
have a soul and a brain
at least a functioning one then it it's
impossible to conceive of how anyone
could be anything less than a totally
horrified and infuriated by the abuse of
children
but we're dealing with people who do not
whose souls and brains do not uh
function at least don't function like a
human being should
you know these are people that are that
have um
uh which isn't to let them off the hook
either
it's not like their brain's
malfunctioning you know through through
no fault of their own
it's just that they're so beholden to
their ideology they've sacrificed their
souls
and uh they don't have they just don't
see it as a problem
and and they also do believe
you know they they do believe that that
children can make choices can consent to
all kinds of things from a very young
age and they won't say it out loud but
that's what they think and there are
there are all kinds of implications to
that horrific viewpoint
and that's part of what we're seeing
here
all right this is from the daily wire
Canadian conservative activist and
YouTuber Lauren Southern announced
Tuesday that her parents had been banned
from vacation rental property company
Airbnb for being closely associated with
their daughter
quote we've removed you from the Airbnb
platform because your account is closely
associated with a person who isn't
allowed to use Airbnb this means you'll
no longer be able to book reservations
on Airbnb Southern was banned from
Airbnb years ago over her right-wing
political views and was denied
reinstatement which he tried to appeal
my parents just got banned from Airbnb
for being related to me Southern
Southern captioned the now viral Twitter
post they have never booked anything for
me they don't represent me in any way
they aren't publicly political in any
way how is this sane in any way
as of Wednesday morning Southern posts
about the ban had received more than 6.8
million views
um
and then there's the follow-up
Airbnb told the daily wire do I reached
out the Banning of Southern's parents
was a mistake so they were banned and
then Lauren Southern called attention to
it and now they're saying I'm saying we
have reinstated their account and said
apologize to them for this mistake
the daily wire reached out to Southern
about the response and she said she
believes Airbnb is lying about the BAM
being a mistake and only backtrack
because of the public blowback
yeah that's exactly what happened that's
not a mistake so what does that mean
mistake it's like someone someone
tripped and fell and accidentally banned
love it Lauren Southern's parents
someone hit a button by accident like
some sort of typo no this was a decision
that they made
there was no basis for it
um as she said it wasn't like she was
trying to evade the band by having her
parents book reservations for it that
didn't happen
it was it was a they they banned her
which was completely insane when they
did it but they banned her years ago
and
and the other thing too is that Lawrence
other mentioned that
her parents never appealed it
okay so it's not like they appealed it
and made their case it it's so so it
when when Airbnb went back on this
decision
they weren't responding to an appeal
they were responding to public pressure
that's what they're responding to which
is which is good it's good that the
public was able to pressure them and
they and that uh
that we were able to exert that kind of
power it's a good thing to know that we
could do
but it's also very disturbing because
what it means
is that they this was kind of they're
testing the waters they were seeing if
they could get away with it
um and if they could have
if Southern you know even just like
wasn't on Twitter so she couldn't post
about it let's say she had been banned
by Twitter also and so I wasn't able to
call anyone's attention to this then
yeah this this would have stayed in
place no matter what even if it had been
appealed
so this is just this is testing the
waters
we already have these big corporate
Brands and companies and platforms that
are Banning people for wrong think and
now they want to expand that to even
Banning your family members they want to
they want to erase all of you uh as far
as you know being consumers of their
products and their services goes
and I'm afraid that one of the lessons
that they might learn from this
it's not gonna they're not gonna learn
the right lesson it's like they're gonna
have a come to Jesus moment and say you
know this that was really too far we
shouldn't do that
like it's bad enough that we're
punishing Lauren Southern for having
political views we don't agree with uh
punish her parents too that's overboard
it's like that's not the conclusion
they're gonna draw
um I think one conclusion they might
draw is that okay this needs to be more
like if we want to erase these people
then it has to be a more
um
you know it it the effort has to be more
coordinated
so the real mistake as far as Airbnb is
concerned is that yeah they banned
Southern and then banned her parents but
she still had access to all these other
platforms so she was able to call
attention to it
so then the the elites and the powers
would be what they're going to then
decide is that well we need to make sure
that when we do this we erase you from
everything so you have no means to speak
out against us
and they are that's already the
conclusion that they've drawn we've seen
them do that to uh several people
um but they can't do it on Twitter now
because they don't they don't control
Twitter at the moment
all right what else do we got here
um okay one other
I want to mention one I've had this
sitting on on deck for a few days so I'm
just going to mention it this is from
Fox News
a New York middle school is apologizing
after serving students with a meal on
the first day of Black History Month
that was deemed to be culturally
insensitive
administrators at Nyack Middle School
say that the hot lunch menu was changed
by the vendor without their knowledge on
February 1st the first day of Black
History Month to include chicken and
waffles with a watermelon dessert with
the which the schools principal called
an unfortunate situation
we're extremely disappointed by this
regrettable situation apologize to the
entire niac Community for the cultural
insensitivity displayed by our food
service providers
I am disappointed that aramack would
serve items that differed from the
published monthly menu especially items
that reinforce negative stereotypes
concerning the African-American
community
and then also there's going to be I
think cultural sensitivity and all of
the sorts of things and their apologies
and all the rest of it
here's what I'm trying to figure out
so
it reinforces negative stereotypes
why exactly is it a negative stereotype
that a lot of black people like chicken
and waffles
why is that negative it's just is is it
is it inaccurate
like it is true that you tend to find
chicken and waffle restaurants and those
sorts of dishes
um in Black communities more than in not
in you know white communities
so
why is that a problem to notice
I like chicken and waffles too it's a
great it's it's it makes sense it's a
great it's a it's a great dish
actually hadn't had it I had it for the
first time like a year ago I've never
had chicken waffles before and um and
then I had it the first time of year I'm
like this is it always sounded a little
bit weird to me like how do you find
chicken waffles that's something then I
had them like this is amazing I love
this
so it's a great food it's great dish
um I think it's accurate to say that it
tends to be
more popular and prevalent in the black
community
I'm not sure if historically it was like
it was uh the first design or or you
know if the first person to come up with
uh the chicken waffles dish was a black
person I don't know if that's the case
but who cares why is it automatically
offensive what a negative stereotype
what's negative about it
this is this is what we've done we
decided that every stereotype is
automatically negative
simply because it's a stereotype but
that's not the case a stereotype is a
it's a
it's a it's a generality
um uh made about groups it's like it's
speaking in a kind of general term about
a group
and that's that's that is not Autumn now
there there can be negative stereotypes
there are things you could say about
groups that are not accurate that are
not true uh that could be degrading or
offensive but not everything is just
because you're making a general
statement and saying you know people in
this group generally like this or do
this or whatever
it's it can be true it's okay to notice
it
but this is the conditioning it's the
conditioning they want where they're
telling us that that we're not allowed
to notice things or at least we need to
ask permission
there are certain things we're allowed
to notice and other things we're not
allowed to notice and we need to get
permission first
and the fact that the the unacceptable
things the things that we're not allowed
to notice the fact that this is so
arbitrarily determined
that's part of the game here it's part
of the as I was talking about this kind
of societal game of Simon Says
so you are allowed to speak in general
terms about black people so Black
History Month is all about
you're allowed to talk about things like
black history
so there are there are and if you were
to say well we're celebrating black
history we're celebrating Black Culture
that'd be okay thing to say you're
allowed to say that we're going to
celebrate Black Culture for Black
History Month okay you can do that
that's speaking in general terms now
but then what is Black Culture exactly
so we're allowed to celebrate it but
what what what what qualifies
especially when you get into things like
food what are you allowed to say is part
of that
scene
that's when the rules become extremely
arbitrary and there's just no way you as
a reasonable rational person there's no
way to know well I'm allowed to notice
that uh that this food tends to be a
part of that but not this food that
food's wrong we can't bring that up
uh it's completely ridiculous all right
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
Bubby says Matt was probably the kid who
brought the American defense figurines
to a GI Joe sleepover uh yeah look and
if the sleepover was at my house we were
having fruity O's for breakfast not uh
not uh Fruit Loops we were uh we were
definitely you know we were having the
the Frosted Mini squares rather than the
Frosted Mini Wheats that was my my mom
was the queen of off-brand
stuff she could just fights like there's
there's an off-brand version of
everything and uh that was my house 100
and when you've got you know I had five
brothers and sisters that just come to
the territory
um we should be doing that more in my
house like my my wife for some reason
still buy she buys my kids the name
brand cereal she refuses to get the
off-brand cereal and so we're paying a
like a 3X premium it tastes basically
the same
and uh so this is this is a discussion
but I'll probably not relevant to the
rest of you uh Kenny says is it such a
horrible thing for someone to take their
own life if there's nothing else we have
control over it should be whether we
live and suffer or bring about an end
that was coming anyway that's a thought
I've never had to entertain and I hope I
never do but if I do it's definitely a
personal decision
well here's the thing Kenny it is
horrible to take care of life I mean
suicide is a horrible thing and I think
that you understand that and even the
people that like most of the people that
say that they
don't necessarily agree well
if if you were
walking across a bridge and you saw a
guy about to throw himself off of it to
kill himself you would try to stop him
wouldn't you
you wouldn't stand there and say well
it's his own decision I guess he's
trying to end his suffering no you would
try to stop him because
and and in fact if you saw someone else
just standing there watching while it
happened you would think that person's a
terrible scumbag and they would be
yeah suicide is a terrible thing
but more to the point when it comes to
euthanasia
doctors shouldn't kill people that's the
principle here
so
you can
try to argue that a person has the right
to take their life or it's okay for a
person to take their own life
I don't agree with that
um at least on a moral level maybe say
someone has a legal right to take their
own life well it's that's the kind of
thing like obviously it can't I can't
really if someone kills themselves
obviously there's no way to legally
enforce the law against it after the
fact but I don't think we have the moral
right to end our own lives but that's a
separate conversation
because we're not talking about what
people have the right to do to
themselves when it comes to euthanasia
we're talking about what do doctors have
the right to do to people
and what I'm saying is that no doctor
has the right to directly and
intentionally kill another person
whether that person is an infant in the
womb or that person is uh you know is
terminally ill or that person is
depressed
that should not be
a tool in the medical toolbox
because it's not medicine medicine
treats medicine heals
anything that doesn't do that is not
medicine and so should not be within the
purview of a doctor
and
finally do we have time for this one
yeah sort of well not really but Nick
says why you got to come after Trump all
the time it really cast your credibility
into doubt it seems like reading from
the script
of course I always get any time that I
criticize Trump that I'm always told
that I always criticize Trump when um it
has always been the case that I in
general I talk about Trump and I talk
about politicians probably less than
almost any conservative in media you
know I don't I don't focus on these
issues that much I like to focus on
other things
so criticize him all the time I think
all automatically is quite inaccurate
my policy has always been that I
criticized Trump when he does things
that that I think are wrong
and then if he doesn't then I don't
criticize him if that's something I
think is right then I'll defend him in
fact just yesterday on the show
when when bide was taking uh taking
credit for putting a cap on the price of
insulin I said no Trump did that okay so
that's that's something that Trump did
give him credit for that
but
Trump also tried to defame
uh DeSantis as a groomer
because he took a picture with some
women
and I think that's wrong so I criticized
him for that so that's basically my
Approach I think that's a a rational
reasonable approach
and just so you understand something too
because I I it it still it kind of
boggles my mind that people don't get
this
is that
criticizing when it comes to Trump
like when it comes to Trump there are
there are
the the sort of grifting profitable
reading from the script
um sacrificing your credibility approach
to Trump is always going to be on the
extremes okay so someone who
always loves Trump and supports
everything he does no matter what
um and always Trump person
that's a grift and the other side the
people who uh hate Trump so much that
then they when supported Hillary Clinton
and now they support the Democrats and
Bill Crystal like hates Trump so much
that he just decided to go and become a
leftist despite him that's also a grift
okay
um
and then and there's because there's
there's like a built-in audience for
both of those it's a simple it's a
simplistic sort of position there's a
built-in audience
anything in between
we take the in-between approach where
you're like well
when he does things I agree with I
criticize him but he does the guy I
agree with I support them if not I
criticize them
um there's no grift there because that's
you're automatically going to be
upsetting people on both sides and so
anytime you do that it's it's hard to
call that a grifter to say that well
you're reading from a script
it's like with Trump the easy especially
as a conservative
the easiest thing has always been either
just become a full-on leftist and then
maybe you get the CNN hits and maybe you
get something on MSNBC so you could do
that or to say well he's uh he's God
incarnate and everything he does is
right
trying to be reasonable about it that's
never been like really the most
profitable position on the guy or on any
positive but that's the correct position
on any politician
so I'm not sitting here and saying that
we should be the in the middle like
being in the middle is the right thing
all the time
when it comes to to issues to principles
the middle is not the right place to be
but when it comes to a person a
politician I think the right thing is to
support them
uh when they have earned it and not when
they don't
a couple weeks ago we told you about how
YouTube removed an episode of our show
because my comments about men who want
to have uteruses and planted in their
bodies were deemed to be offensive and
hateful somehow these restrictive speech
policies exist because the world is on a
mission to make you woke it's as simple
as that but our good friend Dennis
Prager is on a mission to make you wise
and thankfully Dennis has created a
brand new series with daily wire plus
called the Masters program to do just
that we've had a long-standing
relationship with Dennis Prager for good
reason he's been leading the charge
against stupidity for longer than I've
been alive with content like prageru's
five minute videos well the Masters
program takes 40 years worth of wisdom
and experience from one of the most
influential conservative thinkers in
America today and distills it all down
in a way that is relevant and accessible
episodes explore topics like is human
nature basically good I think we could
say for certain that uh I'm obviously
good but I can't speak for anyone else
so we'll find out more about that the
series also covers the consequences of
secularism which by the way are so dire
needed two episodes to explore a brand
new episode of prageru Masters program
is available to stream right now but
only on daily wire plus so so I do
dailywireplus.com to become a member and
watch prageru master's program and more
that's dailywireplus.com today now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
it is perhaps Cosmic Justice that Sam
Smith and Kim Petras perform their
Satanic ritual at the Grammys and though
they they did succeed in getting some of
the attention they crave still most of
the conversation surrounding their
performance has been focused not on the
performance but on Madonna's face the
Aging former pop star introduced the two
men on Sunday night and ever since then
people have been remarking on the fact
that Madonna looked like she was having
a potentially fatal reaction to
shellfish joke like um Marilyn Manson
reimagined as a muppet she looked like
uh she looks like she paid 15 bucks to a
caricature artist to draw a picture of
her and then brought the drawing to her
plastic surgeon and said turn me into
this
and I'm not being mean here and I'm just
trying to be precise in my description
it's important to be very precise
um but it's not my fault that Madonna
now looks like a large flightless bird
that went extinct in the pleistocene era
you can't blame me for the fact that
Madonna looks like a sock puppet she
just does
now Madonna herself seems to have
noticed the comments and the comparisons
and the fact that people are saying that
she looks like a ventriloquist dummy
from a Jeff Dunham act and so she sent
out this tweet on Tuesday
she said the world is threatened by my
power and my stem stamina my
intelligence and my will to survive but
they will never break me this is all a
test
she's right actually speaking for myself
I am blown away by her will to survive
and she has a net worth of only 850
million dollars after all I don't know
how she manages to endure to keep going
to survive against the odds but she does
she Wills her way through it with sheer
guts and determination and copious
amounts of Botox it is inspiring
inspiring at least to the New York Times
so while everyone else has been making
fun of Madonna the New York Times has
swooped in to explain why we should
actually admire her for destroying her
face with plastic surgery in an essay
titled Madonna's new face is a brilliant
provocation the author the author
Jennifer weiner writes quote
with blonde braids looped over her ears
dressed in a long black skirt and black
jacket accessorized with a riding crop
one of the best female recording artists
of all time stepped into the spotlight
of the 65th annual Grammy Awards Sunday
night Madonna was there to introduce Sam
Smith and Kim Petrus a non-binary
performer and a trans woman she began by
referring to her four decades in the
music industry and praised the rebels
forging A New Path and taking the heat
for all of it
was anyone listening social media's
loudest Roars weren't about her speech
or her long time lgbtq advocacy or her
upcoming World Tour they were about
Madonna's printer naturally smooth and
extravagly sculpted face
all of Madonna's features looked
exaggerated pushed and Polished to an
extreme there was her forehead smooth
and gleaming as a porcelain bowl bowl
her eyebrows bleached and plucked to
near invisibility her cheekbones with
deep Hollows beneath them
people posted with a picture side by
side with that of Jigsaw from saws and
Janus from The Muppet Show and made
jokes about Desperately Seeking surgeon
while extremely online plastic surgeons
hastened to guess about exactly what
procedure she had undergone
well there's that and now comes apart
where the leftist writer does what
leftist writers love to do more than
anything which is to try to make simple
vanity seem interesting
she continues beyond the question of
what she'd done however lay the more
interesting question of why she had done
it then Madonna get sucked so deep into
the Vortex of beauty culture that she
came out the other side had the pressure
to appear younger somehow made her think
that she ought to look like some kind of
excessively contoured baby perhaps so
but I'd like to think that our era's
greatest chameleon no a woman who was
always been intentional about her
reinvention was doing something slyer
more subversive
by serving us both a new if not
necessarily improved face and a side of
critique about the work of beauty the
inevitability of aging and the
impossible bind which older female
celebrities find themselves
people complain that she no longer looks
like like Madonna but which Madonna
comes to mind she's been a blonde and a
brunette Butch and high Femme she's worn
cast-offs and Couture she's adopted and
abandoned an English accent she's shown
us her roots and her underwear
deliberately putting the hidden Parts on
display every new version of Madonna was
both a look and a commentary on looking
a statement about the artifice of beauty
and about her own right to set the terms
by which she was seen is it possible
that Madonna has been so blinkered by
her Fame and wealth that she's lost the
ability to see herself objectively yes
but whatever her intentions the
superstar has gotten us all talking
about how good looks are subjective and
how ageism is pervasive
in the end whether she meant to make a
statement or just to look younger better
refreshed Almost Doesn't Matter if
beauty is a construct Madonna's the one
who puts its scaffolding on display
okay first of all
no
um that's not what's going on here two
points
as for beauty being a construct and
subjective
Madonna's face is actually a perfect
example demonstrating why that is not
the case
despite the extremely common
misperception beauty is not merely in
the eye of the beholder there is an
objective quality to it see everyone
agrees that Madonna's artificial face is
not beautiful everyone agrees that all
the injections and surgeries and
Plastics have not improved anything
women uh you know everyone knows that a
woman who ages naturally and gracefully
is more beautiful than one who
obsessively goes under the knife in a
desperate and futile attempt to reverse
the clock why do we all feel that way is
it entirely arbitrary have we settled on
this view randomly do we all happen to
have the same artificially constructive
subjective opinion about beauty
No in fact
we recognize even if we don't realize we
recognize the objective qualities of
beauty
we know even if we don't know that we
know that beauty is is wholeness
completeness
beauty is found in order in symmetry
something as beautiful if it reflects
its own Essence and if that Essence is
good
that's why a beautiful tree is one that
has grown tall and mighty not one that
is rotting and diseased and you know
covered with graffiti
Thomas Aquinas said that beauty consists
in due proportion and you know I think
this is basically what he's getting at
Madonna's fake face isn't beautiful
we all see that it isn't beautiful
because it's a rejection of what is
natural and true
it is a reflection not of her
humanness and her Humanity in her
Womanhood but of her vanity and her
self-obsessions and her insecurity
there's nothing beautiful about that and
so there's nothing beautiful about her
face
truly the idea
that beauty is subjective it probably
stands alone as the one Viewpoint that
nearly everyone professes
and yet no one really believes so you
think that you think that beauty is
subjective but you don't really believe
that and I know that you don't believe
it because here's how I know it then you
know I don't know anything about you
whoever you are listening to this
but
what I do know is that you would be
appalled
if somebody were to look out upon a
snow-capped mountain range or a lake
glistening in the sunset or someone
looked at a Rembrandt painting or who
heard a very talented choir singing
Amazing Grace and if that person
recoiled and said ew gross this is
disgusting
now you'd be you would be appalled by
someone who reacted that way you would
think that they were insane
you would not say well beauty is in the
eye of the beholder I mean that's a
perfectly valid reaction you wouldn't
now people may may resonate differently
with these sights and sounds some may be
more moved than others but no sane
person is actively repulsed by any of
those things nobody outside the walls of
an insane asylum experiences actual
revulsion at a sunset
these are Timeless and Universal
beauties
and we're told that each culture
reinvents Beauty for itself and yet what
we actually find is that all through
history and across time in fact every
culture arrives at strikingly similar
conclusions about what is beautiful
now there may be cultures that have
difficulty creating beautiful things our
culture for instance and cultures who
intentionally create ugly things instead
of beautiful again ours
but everybody knows what is beautiful
nobody would prefer a bathroom stall
splattered with urine stains over the
Sistine Chapel
nobody would because one is grotesque
and filthy
the other is beautiful
and we can all see that final Point
women like Madonna who refuse to age
gracefully are they are not victims of
ageism
except perhaps the ageism they direct
against themselves
really they're a reflection of a culture
that fears mortality
okay we we worship death because we we
worship youth because we are afraid of
death this is like if you want to call
it it's death ISM I guess
and it really is as simple as that
that's why we worship youth because
we're afraid of death now you may think
that both of these things worshiping
Youth and being afraid of death are
inevitable in every society but you're
wrong because traditionally especially
in more ancient times the elders in the
community have been revered and
respected age was associated with wisdom
it wasn't shameful to be seen as old but
rather there was honor and dignity that
came with being of advanced age
yet yet these were also societies that
accepted the reality of death death was
a part of life for them they were they
were rounded all the time they may have
had different ways of understanding
death different ideas about what
happened after you died but but they
didn't hide from Death itself not nearly
to the extent that we do today anyway
these days it's considered rude to even
ask somebody their age
somehow the fact that you've been
walking the Earth for more than 20 years
is supposed to be embarrassing
but why should it be why should a 65
year old woman be embarrassed that she's
well for no other reason than the fact
that 65 year old women are likely closer
to death than 25 year old women and we
see age as proximity to death and death
is the one thing we don't want to be
reminded of
and so that's why we reject the aging
process entirely
indeed much of modern society is I'm
convinced fundamentally set up to
distract us from thinking about our own
deaths
but death is inevitable whether we think
about it or not
and Madonna is 64 years old whether she
Embraces that reality or not
so she might as well embrace it
there's no shame in being whatever age
you are there is only shame in being
ashamed of it
and that's why ultimately Madonna is
today canceled and that'll do it for
this portion of the shows and move over
to the members block hope to see you
there if not talk to you on Friday
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]